let's talk about some of the investments
you're making i know that you've been
public about kind of the the specific
assets that you're investing in and it's
pretty diversified portfolio you've got
bitcoin ethereum solana polygon and
others
i want to talk about just quickly if you
can run through your general framework
of how you determine where you're going
to allocate capital so
i have come to the conclusion on all all
things digital the best way to look at
it and i've said this several times
bitcoin is not a coin it's software
ethereum is not
a blockchain it's software it's all
software hbar software
and and so what i do is i say to myself
i've seen this movie before i was an
investor in software you know engineers
22 years ago at the learning company
when we made educational software
so the way i used to do it then is the
way i'm doing it now i'm very lucky guy
i can make a phone call and it always
gets returned that's the whole shark
tank thing and i get all that but if i
want to invest in polygon i want to meet
the engineering team which i did in
dubai i called him up met him at the
team
heard their vision of what they're doing
looked at the economic reality of the
outcome the potential of it so
first is team i want to meet the team
if i if i check the box on team smart
guys good engineers good strategy good
group i'm interested here's the test the
second test
what economic value are they creating in
the case of polygon let's stay on that
polygon for a second aggregating
transactions to reduce gas fees on each
is a smart idea there's a reason you
would do that because you have an
economic reason to pursue that you save
money transaction fees are less so i
think the potential of that is large
h bar okay great team good engineers
what's the economic premise that would
keep that
growing well boeing wants a quasi
centralized decentralized platform they
want the best of both worlds hbar can
deliver that check the box there buy
into that one too
look what's going on with you know
solana i mean they're trying to solve
problems a different way too speed
everything up check the box who's
working on that sam bankman freedom his
team why wouldn't you bet that horse so
it's all about getting positions in all
of these
you know
software platforms that's what they are
they're software platforms so i say
institutions
you're you criticize me for investing in
bitcoin you own a big position of
microsoft do you want a five percent
waiting in yahoo what is that that's
software why don't you do the same thing
in bitcoin why don't you do the same
thing in ethereum why aren't you an hbo
why aren't you polygon why aren't you in
serum why aren't you in helium like it's
all software
and so with that attitude on it's hard
to say i'll only invest in publicly
traded software companies one day these
to me and i really believe this one day
crypto and all these software platforms
are going to be the 12th sector of the s
p and i'm just taking the bet now that
we're on our way there and i'm taking
and staking my bets now
broad portfolio you know no one ethereum
is my biggest position right now
bitcoin's had a bit of a correction i
get it but there's been volatility but
now
to offset that volatility
i own an exchange
so i want to own more exchanges
i look at it it's all software